puzzle from
one of the greatest puzzlers of the last
two centuries perhaps that's putting it
out there this guy called sam lloyd you
can look him up this is one of his most
famous puzzles and he patented it and
sold millions of sort of physical copies
so i've made myself a physical copy it's
quite hard to get the originals and if
you do get an original worth a lot of
money the puzzle is called get off the
earth the the center bit moves and i
just made it with a paper clip and
printed this out but the racial
stereotyping kind of want to move away
from so there are some equivalent
puzzles which i'm going to show you i
made the digital copy and i found one
that sam lloyd also made to do with a
bunch of bicyclists that boys with flags
around a bicycle and it moves in a
similar way i invite you to count the
number of cyclists around this wheel one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve thirteen
not rocket science
uh on card i'll just be spinning the
inner wheel and the same question now
brady count them where do you want me to
start see the b okay one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve
i can see his face
the text underneath says turn the disc
so the arrow points to a and count 13
boys then move the arrow to b and there
are only 12 boys so they agree with what
you've just said and the question is
which boy has vanished and where did he
go
let's just check
count heads okay we'll count heads one
two three four five six seven eight nine
10 11 12 13. definitely 13 heads
shift it around
heads yeah one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven
twelve
heads
do you wanna count legs uh i don't think
it's the situation's gonna change i
still think it's something to do with
the way the boys are drawn but something
to do with the way the boys are drawing
do you want to say more about your
instincts here you've got good instincts
today brady your instincts are
are important so what is it about the
way they're drawn that you think you're
suspicious about i just think i just
think something that was a head turned
into not a head
like a shoe or something really yeah
[Music]
i mean let's find a candidate right so
that this head get gets cut in half
but then there's a bit of a head here
that it kind of joins with right it
joins up there
and it got replaced the other half of
the head here and this one gets lost a
bit but they're still there
some funky things going on this leg here
i think is a left leg and when i slide
it's now a right leg that's interesting
i don't know if that messes up your
account but it shouldn't change how many
heads there are in my opinion the key is
there where the two are together this is
here that's gotta be key
well but there's still two heads right
yeah
and they're just separated there they
are they're still there there's nothing
tricky going on
but it's uh that's i think that's the
key this is one of those puzzles that's
frustrating and it caused a stir back in
the day because it feels so simple
there's nothing tricky going it's a
piece of paper you can actually touch it
you can move it around there's nothing
to conceal really
but something surprising is going on you
start to doubt your counting ability uh
you start counting from different places
you count the heads maybe you count the
flags and it's one of those puzzles that
feels insulting to your intelligence and
that's why it splits people into like
really annoying
something tricky is going on and
fundamentally doubting the very core of
your being like i can't count to 12.
nothing should change when you spin that
so it there's something subtle going on
and i thought i'd explain it there's
some other variations of this puzzle i
thought we'd show you so martin gardner
wrote about this one and i found one
that he made this time it's not in a
circle let's do some counting together
brady how many faces six i agree how
many faces
so which face disappeared
i mean there are still six hats and i
can shift back
ah but there's only five chins well the
chin's just a horizontal one there hmm
the first thing to comment is that like
a magic trick this is done less as a
magical more of just like what's going
on but that's what magic really is
um the question of how many faces is a
valid question but it has two different
answers in the two configurations in the
spinny version or this version the
second question which is where did the
bicyclist go which one disappeared or
which face disappeared or which face
appeared
that's the misdirection
i think that question is
invalid
and that's why you should ask it to sort
of apply this direction because if you
ask someone to describe what happens to
the faces you get a different bit of
attention tell me about these faces
maybe compared to those faces maybe tell
me about the height of them they're
different heights they're different eyes
yeah in fact they're different faces
none of the original faces are still
there there's six faces none of those
faces exist anymore there are five new
faces so that's why that question is
misleading i think which face has been
all of them and we made five new faces
which are fundamentally different in
fact they're a bit longer
do you begin to see what's going on when
you simplify it this much it begins to
get insulting one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven agreed
yeah all right so in the other puzzles i
shifted something i'm just gonna shift
something on this diagram
now i know you saw what happened but how
many lines are there one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten and
they're 11 just now i'm going to go back
again
11 lines which line appeared disappeared
is a nonsense question agreed i don't
really know i'm kind of baffled this is
so simple that it's baffling there are
definitely 11 lines here and what i've
actually done is i sliced them along
that line and i just shifted everything
along that line slid it there and now
there are only 10 lines but they're all
a bit longer so which line disappeared
none of them that's the effect we're
happening when you say which lines
appeared well this is nonsense question
actually i've just made 10 new lines
from bits of the old ones that are a bit
longer
so imagine that situation put the lines
at different heights and slice
horizontally so here's that's just
another version of the same thing you
count the lines but then you shift them
different number of lines
some of them are different lengths i've
done this randomly and now it's really
obvious that some of them have
fundamentally changed it's just a
different set of lines with a different
number going on and that wouldn't be
impressive to anybody what you could do
though let's work this around a circle
like the first two things we saw we're
done on a circle so it's basically
taking that line that i've sliced some
lines and wrapping it around you can see
that i get a rotational thing here so
let's just count the lines here one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
and they're all certain length if i then
switch it round
we have a little bit of a conflict you
can see there are two lines next to each
other they could be counted as one line
but if they were more identifiable you
could see that they're they're two
different lines there's two lines of
roughly that length one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven if
you start getting clever wrapping this
cut around a circle and realizing all
that's happening is you're making new
lines appear which are slightly longer
and if they're not a lot longer they
look very like the old lines you get a
little glimpse of what an artistic
version of this could look like so we'll
go back to the face imagine these lines
there are six lines and if i shift them
over now there are only five of them but
they're all a bit longer and so if you
design the faces cleverly this guy is
his eyes are there they look a bit like
eyebrows but they actually become
eyebrows on this guy's face so there's
some artistic cleverness to make the
identifiers a little bit subtle and now
there are five faces where there
previously were six but they're
different faces they're all a bit longer
it's exactly equivalent to the lines if
we go back to our bicyclist we've gone
back to the circle idea we've drawn 13
boys and you can see they're getting
they're getting further and further in
on the circle a bit like our lions got
shifted and when you shift it we're just
splicing together bits of boys all the
boys disappeared and 12 new boys
appeared which are all a bit longer but
they're designed artistically enough so
it's really hard to tell on a bit of
paper everything's slightly imprecise
and artistically we forgive any sort of
slight misalignments and there are quite
a few so tell me with the boys
where did the 12 to 13 heads change
because heads aren't lines heads aren't
lines but there are definitely
13 heads except some of them are very
clear heads and obviously they're not
changing this one up here is not
changing
and the ones inside are not changing but
the crucial thing is around these edges
where the head is intersected by the
line
that's where we splice together bits of
two other heads
and the new head we get is slightly
longer or slightly shorter or just
slightly smaller and if you like you can
see that this this guy's head here
is quite fat
and when i shift it
it's even fatter
like a super fat head and that's
happening in a softer way all around the
body parts the legs the heads it's this
is a really lovely mixture of a really
simple piece of maths like you can
splice lines and they look similar but a
bit longer
done artistically into a way that
completely bamboozles clever people who
have their wits about them they know how
to count 13 and 12 and yet that little
shift
changes the fundamental reality of the
number here it's it's a nice example of
a puzzle that's been around a long time
but even when you understand it there's
still something slightly bamboozling
about it
a great thing about the puzzle in
today's video was how it was interactive
you could slide it back and forward look
closely like on your own terms and
that's also a great thing about the
courses on brilliant today's episode
sponsor these are from brilliant's
pre-algebra course
as you can see pretty interactive but as
you can also see here there's plenty
more where that came from
if you want to get smarter to give your
brain a workout that's both fun and
educational you can't go past brilliant
and it's huge range of courses puzzles
daily challenges a brilliant premium
subscription which unlocks all this
great stuff is also a great gift for
youngsters and lifelong learners
go to brilliant.org
unmade it's there on the screen for 20
off that subscription
you won't regret it our thanks to
brilliant
[Music]
special thanks to these people for
supporting us on patreon you can join
them go to patreon.com
numberphile
but not just them thanks to everyone
who's taken the time to watch this
number file video
[Music]
you